peace be with you thank you for tuning
in to the Dene show every week we're
here with a new show helping you
understand the purpose of life fastest
growing way of life in the world
according to the Guinness Book of World
Records this is no joke but the most
misunderstood and we're here helping you
understand Muslims Islam and we have so
many people today coming over from all
walks of life we have our next guest
coming up
what made this man who was a born
Christian and him he fooled around in
life and he got serious with life and he
started living the purpose of life and
today he's here on the D show to tell us
his story we'll be right back
you don't wanna go nowhere this is
this is the this is the thing you wanna
come sit down more o'clock
Shadid Muhammad formerly known as should
be mama she nodded so I opened the show
you heard me talk about you went from
being a Christian to fooling around in
life to get serious with life to live in
the purpose of life we all go through
stages in our lives that we just we're
kind of lost in the jungle confused so
introduce yourself to our viewing
audience and tell us a little bit about
yourself where you started when you
started and how you got here today home
did he love my name is Shadid Muhammad I
got started when my parents decided to
you know do it adults do and I think
that was the probably the start of my
life okay and then somewhere in the
process I kind of got lost in the system
and I mean that literally what city were
you born in I was born in Montclair New
Jersey okay yeah
yeah mountainside hospital to be exact
I wasn't born a Christian but I was I
was born to Christian parents who
themselves weren't really practicing
Christians that I mean myself growing up
much like many children who grow up
without a religious foundation
I found myself grappling with a lot of
lessons there were lessons in life but I
didn't understand at that particular
moment that they were lessons I think as
non-muslims a lot of us we tend to look
at the things that confront us in life
and we tend to blame God I was an angry
baby you know just considering my
circumstances so my attitude was always
I didn't ask to be here God put me here
he told me and the world owes me that
was my attitude all the way up until
probably the time that I took Shahada
I took Shahada at 20 years old so you
can understand for the past twenty years
of my life has been walking around with
this chip on my shoulder that I didn't
ask to be here I mean I literally used
to curse God I would look up at the
heavens and I would say I hate you you
would literally do that nice I would
literally do it I hate you why me
questioning God you know I mean mind you
you're talking about a child that didn't
understand life didn't understand God
didn't endure didn't have a religious
foundation nothing and there are tons of
non Muslims out there today that can
relate to what I'm talking about where
you begin to curse God and you know
because you're looking at all of the
things that confront you in your life
and you're saying you know why is my
life like this what did I do to deserve
this
I didn't even ask
born God brought in here and then take
me through all of this stuff that I
didn't ask to be born to begin with and
so your attitude is that the world owes
me God owes me and it's a favorite very
you know self-destructive attitude to
have because this is the type of person
who doesn't care about life and if a
person doesn't care about their own life
you can only imagine how they feel about
your life you tried to write a song
about it that no no but I try to let the
world know about how I felt through my
self-destructive behavior hmm a lot of
what we see with a lot of the teens and
the youth that are out there now that
with the pants saggin you know if the
tattoos on those are just self
expressions of frustration pitaka salatu
wassalam he warned us about the children
of Xena the children of fornication and
adultery and this is what we're dealing
with today it's not just from a
spiritual or religious perspective but
even from a psychological perspective
you know Xena has so many ramifications
fornication fornication and adultery yes
it has ramifications that don't just
affect the two people that were involved
it affects the child as well and the
community and the society and society at
large
absolutely so I was a product of them I
was a product of that and I've never
made I've never made any excuses for
that I didn't write my scripts so it's
nothing that I have to make excuses for
I'm just hoping to share that with
people so that many of our youth who
understand what I'm talking about that
what I'm saying resonates with them that
they can understand that there is a way
out of that you don't have to continue
living your life like that no and it was
a few incidents that happen in
my life that kind of made me the light
made the light bulb go off of my head
one of them was the death of many of my
friends but one in particular and his
death kind of woke me up and it kind of
made me think that you know is this the
way that I want my life to end and then
you know the light bulb goes off and you
start to contemplate you start to
reflect on life and all of the lessons
that you should have learned along the
way and a lot of times in the only time
for many young african-american youth
the lightbulb tends to go off when you
go to prison lightbulb doesn't go off
for you out in the streets because
there's too many distractions and even
email after him a lot are very beautiful
he said that I made dua I made
supplication to a law that he allowed me
to memorize the Quran he said but I
didn't memorize the Quran until I was in
prison he said so when you make du'a
when you supplicate for something ask
Allah to give it to you while you're in
a good state mean be specific when you
ask for things now sometimes we ask the
things and we're really not prepared to
do what it takes to get what we ask the
loss of henna with Allah for may I ask
Allah for children but there may be some
other things that you may have to go
through some medical procedures some
other things some patience some time
that you have to go through in order for
you to get with what you asked Allah for
and so for me once I lost this
particular friend
I went home one night and I and I cry
and I asked God I always believed in God
I never accepted the idea or the dogma
of the Trinity so you believe in God but
you were cursing God yeah I believe in
God do you see you had like this
relationship it was a relation
yes good ears bad days yes absolutely
all right absolutely
I think the the cursing of God just came
through frustration and not being able
to process you know when human beings
are confronted with traumatic situations
they do one or two things
fight-or-flight we tend to either stay
and fight or run and you know for a
child for me it was to run away from God
which many of our youth are experiencing
that now they're faced with very
difficult the complexities of life that
normally consume most people yeah but we
don't know how to process it so the
thing that we do is to turn we turn our
frustrations on God and begin to blame
him for it why me so your light book
comes on and now you were mentioning
that you couldn't so would you go back
to what your parents were upon the they
weren't really practicing but they were
Christian and you were going to mention
something about about that what happened
then yeah I was I never accepted the
Trinity I was about 11 years old and I
told my mother or my foster mother at
the time that I didn't want to go to
church anymore and she asked me why and
I said because I just I don't believe
and I don't believe she said you don't
believe in God I said now I believe in
God I believe in God I just don't
believe in the Trinity that God Jesus
the Holy Spirit is all one just no
interpretation no explanation was enough
for my heart to accept that none and I
was 11 years old so I went from 11 to 20
just believing in God which was what I
already had I mean I was in church
physically but mentally I was somewhere
somewhere else because I hadn't allah
subhanho wa taala creates the human
being in such a way that we only accept
what is consistent what the intrinsic
nature that Allah created us upon much
like the body if you take a foreign
substance and try to place it in the
body if you take a foreign piece of the
body and you
place it in the body the body will
reject it if you have to get a heart
transplant or any type of transplant in
your body when organ has to be replaced
when they put that organ in your body
they also give you medication to trick
your body into believing that that organ
is your normal organ the moment your
body recognizes that that organ is not
yours
it rejects it Allah created the human
being spiritually in the same way that
he created us believing in one God
believing that he is the only one worthy
of worship he created us believing that
as allah says in the quran pizza dr.
Laham Latifa taught on nasa ally this is
the fitter of allah the natural way that
allah created the human being and never
will you find any alteration in the way
that Allah created you so Allah created
us believing from the beginning that
there is only one God Prophet Muhammad
said that cool umma luden you LeDoux
Alan Fatah bah-bah-ba-wa
will you hold a Neely ariana.sea Ronnie
are you miss Annie but every human being
was created on the pizza believing in
one God and it is his parents that make
him a Jew a Christian or fire worshiper
and notice he didn't say Muslim he
didn't say the parents make him a Muslim
because you're already Muslim he said
his parents make him a Jew a Christian
or an idolatry he didn't say make him a
Muslim why because he was already upon
the belief of a Muslim which is the
belief in one God because a Muslim is
one who submits to the will of God
exactly so you're born in the submission
of state of submission now you started
speaking some Arabic you know are you
here well technically if you learn the
Arabic language and you master that you
are an hour go heat an hour
so but I mean like you and what you're
born you're in Africa african-americans
but your recite your reciting something
Arabic because you went also to study
overseas either your passion is that
right to learn this way of life so we
have this original language that's been
preserved and you've studied it so this
was recording once I took Shahada and I
came home from prison in 2000 I was only
home for a year and I got accepted into
the Islamic University in 2001 so
consider I spent five years of my life
in prison and then only after being home
for a year not even a year I was
selected to go to the Islamic University
so I was a culture shock there I learned
the Arabic language has studied in the
Arabic language for two the Arabic
language Center for two years and then I
went on to the University to study in
the College of hadith which I graduated
with a bachelor's degree in both
sciences
so the Trinity didn't fit father's son
Holy Ghost
you couldn't grasp that that went
against your saying your nature okay
because in Islam is just worshiping God
so now we love many people don't know
that we love Jesus you can't be a Muslim
unless you'd love Jesus is right that he
was one of the mighty messengers of God
so how did you go from now that state
where it was confusing didn't make sense
and most people they just slide in to
church on Sundays right to get with the
music and have the band ever yeah Jesus
but people don't really think you were
thinking you're a young man right so now
you're thinking and we're never trying
to disparage on anybody we really want
you know to to help people to think most
people aren't thinking are they you know
people just you know just blindly
following with their grandparents or
their parents did you're thinking man
thinking young man so now you're
thinking you're like okay
I I just want to call upon God you know
this whole thing is just confusing where
do you go most we're sure I'm going to
get a lot of questions they see they got
the timer right here their time in us so
tell us now what happens next
okay you're just like I'm not going to
church what happens from there
I didn't start a journey in search for
God because I mean at 12 13 14 years old
you're not looking for not you you know
God exists you know there's a higher
power higher being whatever you want to
turn whatever whatever term you want to
use you just go through life you know so
rapidly from the different experience
forward how do you get let's talk about
this how do you get like from being
distracted music is numb in the mind
your mind is just not done zombie and
you just know isn't it true you listen
to jay-z 50 cents and they're like the
icons you're looking up to them it's
like they're not yours artwork isn't a
GCSE level do is I will sometimes I
follow your desires actually Alastair
cross is that I was recording William
they're the one it was about the brand
chip right here
Eminem and all of them they got this
blue I know what you're talking about
so tell us tell us now how do you get
from following your designers to really
think thinking about purpose because
it's not cool nowadays soon as you start
you like ruined the party it's you just
oh my God he's like karate what is that
doing man how did you get to that state
you faster already now well like I said
there were certain events that took
place in my life that actually woke me
up a reality that was always there I
just never took the time out to tap into
yeah in the back of your mind while
you're partying and you're enjoying life
in the back of your mind there's a side
of you that says I know I need to change
everybody that's your conscious talking
to you if you still have one because the
way things are designed today they are
designed to eliminate a conscious from
you all together through subliminal
messages through technology you know
they have the iPhone iPad
IIIi you get where they're going with
you they have smart phone smart water
smart car smart smart smart so if
everything does the thinking for you so
you no longer critically sink down
analyze you know life you know
do that so there are elements that are
working to dumb you down so that you
don't tap into your [ __ ]
I like that dumb you dumb you down yeah
best forward so now someone died yeah I
lost the friend where's a famous rapper
you were talking about before rocky was
a good athlete more famous a Qaddafi
from the the country that the Qaddafi
rapper yes yes now it was yes yeah - box
- yes he dies before New Year's yes what
happens next well you were shot in the
face in a project hallway in Orange New
Jersey at the time that that happened I
was in prison at the time very close
friend of Mines and very close to home I
mean when you lose friends in the
streets you tend to think that you know
it's not a big deal because these are
just associates when it when it happens
to someone that you grew up with you
spent the vast majority of your youth
your adolescence hanging around we start
to wonder am I'm the one that's next or
you start to wonder in my case why was
it him instead of me because I was worse
than he was that's how you think why him
and not me so when that light bulb goes
off you start to say what you know if
God took him instead of me and I was
worse than he was
maybe there's a greater purpose for me
so now that starts your journey to start
to contemplate about all of the lessons
that you've gone through in your life
all of the opportunities that have
passed you by that you didn't take
advantage of and now you start to tap
into that consciousness that's there and
you start to make amends between you and
God so I started with if this is what
you want for me you want me to be alive
then guiding godly Christianity wasn't
an alternative for me something that was
out Judaism was out and the five percent
nation the Nation of Islam all of those
things was out and all of the arrows
were pointing towards the song isn't it
simple many people now they
usually escaped all these religions
everyone's making the claim but if you
just open the books if you just a like
you just said you said guide me guide me
just you know you make that sincere
intention you ask upon the Creator you
don't put an image to a me like a statue
or you don't do that right you don't
have a mental picture just the Creator
and just do your homework that's a
cop-out isn't it just to say oh there's
so many religious it's easy to find out
the truth if you want the truth is that
true absolutely you find out seek and
you shall find seek and you shall find
so now what happens you did you did some
okay Christianity is not an option
you're not some of the Trinity yeah you
excluded some of these others but at the
face of our most people at the face of
them if you open the world religion
books you can see the things just don't
make sense
it is weird so did you do that you
should investigate here there and not to
need to investigate okay me in the
African American neighborhoods and our
environments Islam is very prevalent so
you don't really need to look that far
yeah you can you can spot the truth when
you see it and the moment I saw Islam I
knew it was the truth that was just a
matter of me coming to grips with the
fact that it wasn't you and something
that I needed to embrace you got to be
courageous to accept Islam don't you I
mean because it is yes I mean you think
because it is a lot of effort now would
your parents going to say did you have
that like what are my friends going to
think did you have that peer pressure
some people have that you didn't have
that how about now it's a battle to to
do to leave off the desires right you
have to make that change like you got to
get it you've got people some people
didn't want to give a pork for instance
they love the pig right I know I think
that that's another cop out that's
another so what was he what was what is
it when when it came to you
what was the main thing that what
happened well after you've been dragged
after the dunya has literally dragged
you through the mud I mean you don't
really have those type of hang-ups
anymore you just want salvation you just
want to be saved
you just want out of that life so you've
done it already
absolutely some people keep thinking
that they date is that time I got time
right yeah and then there's some people
who have been beat up so bad that they
just want out they just want to submit
now just want to submit you've given up
okay I say wait it you want to live it
because you've seen at the failed
experience after failed experience that
you can't do it by yourself okay because
you hear what I'm sure have you
experienced people who just okay they
recognize this is the truth but they got
other things on their mind the desire
right they don't want to give up those
are people who haven't really been beat
down like that okay and this is
something that Muslims need to
understand and that is that people
embrace the slam
after having hit rock bottom rock bottom
in life and then they become Muslim and
then when they become Muslim they have
such bad experience with some of the
Islamic communities that there is no
more rock bottom for them and that is
something that we have to be conscious
of but to be cognizant of the fact that
you understand where people have come
from people have come from the bottom
rock bottom they hit rock bottom in
their lives and they turn to the
religion of Islam as that last
alternative for salvation the prosperity
in their lives and then to become a
Muslim and to be bombarded with all of
the fighting and the arguing and
debating and you know the harshness it
kind of makes you feel like what was
left for me I've tried being a Christian
I've tried being a stick of kid I've
tried selling drugs I've tried this I've
tried this I've tried this the only
thing left for me it's them then once I
tried that and I have such a bad
experience with that what else is left
for me and these are things that as
Muslims we have to be cognizant of
because the person that you run into
on a day-to-day basis you don't know
where they came from you don't know what
experiences they had in life that drove
them to take Shahada and we have to have
a more we have to be more sensitive when
we look at people in the Masjid when we
look at religious people we have to be
more sensitive you know to the set so
fast forward I ask God to guide me and
when I got to prison there was a friend
of mine who had been you know
incarcerated for some time and he was a
really bad guy on the streets really bad
guy and when he came to me he had a
chain around his neck what a loss name
in Arabic no mind you as I said that
Islam was very prevalent in the African
American community so it wasn't
something that was foreign to me I knew
what it meant I knew what it represented
but I just couldn't put the two together
him being a Muslim no way no way and I
asked him I said you know I see the
chain around your neck I said are you
Muslim you say yeah I'm Muslim and you
know that was the start I just couldn't
believe it and so he gave me some books
to in particular mo duties introduction
to Islam and the by Autobiography of
Malcolm X the Autobiography of Malcolm X
is distinct I read it three times three
times I didn't complete the fourth time
I was so intrigued how he was able to
embrace something that he believed was
the truth and to refine himself to such
a degree I was so intrigued by that that
I said that that is me I can do that I
can do that I can because a lot of his
experiences I was able to relate it
resonated with me immediately I don't
mean mind you we've seen the movie
Malcolm X we've seen another one with
Denzel we've seen that as children but
it's nothing like reading the biography
at 20 years old having so many different
experiences in your life it adds a whole
nother
mentally and at that moment I realized
that this is where I needed to be and it
was one thing about the religion of
Islam that interests me that resonated
with me so well and that was that
Muslims only believe in one God I said
that's exactly what I believe I've been
believing that since I was a kid this
has to be the truth this has to be the
truth I believe in one God I've been
believing that all my life and it was at
that point that I decided that I needed
to be Muslim but I didn't take Shahada
tell us we're almost out of time for for
the person that needs he hears all of
this garbage this this fellas propaganda
you know and he's confused because every
time he turns on Fox News CNN he sees
something blowing up and Islam radical
and oppresses women and jihad ease and
you know but he's listening to you he's
watching me so it's like you know what
these things making sense but over here
what these guys lying to me what's going
on how do they you know get past these
stereotypes well I think that there's
only a particular type of person that is
influenced by the media the vast
majority of Americans don't believe what
the media says honestly seriously
because no matter what they see on the
news we can't validate that I did a news
interview in Washington DC and a woman
asked me what is I want happy I said I
don't know what it what happiness she
says if you've never heard the term I
said I heard the term before she said so
you don't know what a Wahhabi is I said
I don't know one Muslim who calls
himself a Wahhabi not one I said so by
me even answering your question I'm
validating the term
developing debt reversal of hope there
we're Muslims that's a term that the
media created and we give credence to it
when we accept it hmm I'm not going to
give credence to it and I'm not going to
validate it I don't I don't believe that
there is an American that believes every
single thing that the media says about
Islam because they have neighbors that
almost when they see the media and then
they look at their next-door neighbor
who's been living next door to them for
20 years never had any problems with
them never seen any resemblance and
their behavior and what they see on the
news then they'll accept that they don't
accept that and evidenced by the fact
that people are still coming into the
slam today it hasn't stopped fast is
going to be of life and and there's more
women coming into Islam demands a true
that's a whole nother conversation I'm
did a lot what is the biggest proof or
Aslam someone wants something tangible
right Jesus peace be upon him who we
like we serve members of as a Muslim
Allah CDs and Jesus we know all the
messages of God they came up evidences
improves right Jesus he gave life to the
dead by God's permission here the seat
by God's permission what about the
problem humming peace be upon him and
what about you know what did he bring
look at somebody if they want to look
into Islam to read their thinking
academic it was science they want
something they can feel touch what can
they do the greatest miracle that has
been given to any prophet was given to
Prophet Muhammad Mayhew simplices the
opponent and that miracle was the Quran
the greatest miracle Jesus by the
permission of Allah gave life to the
physical day Prophet Muhammad gave life
to the spiritual day Allah says in the
Quran our main cannon matin rahi aina o
Roger Allen Allah who nor am shiva he
penis come a metal filament laser Vihara
Janina can he who was dead spiritually
to whom we gave life and a light by
which he can walk amongst men be like he
who was steeped in the depths of
darkness from which he can never come
out this verse right here was one of the
first verses that acquainted myself with
when I opened the Quran until today
I have never forgotten this verse
because that verse any one of us who
embraced Islam it resonates with you so
well
can he who was dead to whom we gave life
so Prophet Muhammad gave light to the
dead as well but the spiritual dead
physically the person can guide you can
bring him back to life and he can be the
same sorry individual he was before he
died the first time you can bring a
person back to life spiritually and
he'll change the world so would you
recommend for every human being is that
their right that they pick up this Quran
that they read it that no book ever
killed the person did it so would you
recommend for every person to evaluate
test this book and if they're sincere
and if they study it scientifically
analytically they'll see like over 1.5
billion people have that this is indeed
from the creator of the heavens and
earth this Quran the English is
obviously the translation the Arabic is
the original but even if they read it in
a good English translation that they'll
be able to see that this is from the
Creator absolutely final closing
comments and advice for our viewers we
got 30 seconds I love you listen me but
got 10 to 10 second you guys know if
somebody wants to to hear more about you
do you have a website you have a day at
your personal phone number how do you
address that looking wwr Olga R AWD eh
org thank you very much me the critter
that has an earth world you for being
which is aqua hi thank you why yeah and
thank you for tuning in to the D show as
our guests so eloquently put it just he
loves you and we love you but the
Creator loves you more
first and foremost but do you love the
Creator that's them that's the question
if you do you're going to take the
necessary steps to get to know him so
pick up this Quran it's the only book in
the world that in this book that's been
memorized by millions the living miracle
we have it in its original preserve save
tamper free tamper proof hasn't been
changed to suit the times as it was
revealed we have it today and addresses
you the human being
says don't they reflect ponder and think
had this book been from other than the
crater Allah you would find in it many
contradictions discrepancies find one
it's a challenge it's a challenge but
are you going to pick it up do you love
the crater pick it up read it and put it
to the test we'll see you next time and
you know what you can get it for free
man I mean what kind of deal is that
call us at 1-866-376-8255 but I love
egg-bound Subhan Allah alhamdulillah la
illaha in na na na egg bum love I